- [snorts, grunts]
HELLO?
- HEY, IT'S LIZ, YOUR PUBLICIST.
I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO CALL YOU FOR AN HOUR.
NOW YOU HAVE THE RADIO
INTERVIEW, LIKE, NOW.
- OH, ALL RIGHT.
- SO JUST, LIKE,
TALK ABOUT THE ALBUM.
JUST DO IT, OKAY?
JUST DO IT.
BE CHILL.
- YEAH.
- NOW WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF SPEAKING TO A VERY
IMPORTANT MUSICIAN,
WHO HAS A NEW "BEST OF" ALBUM.
ON THE AIR,
YOU'RE ON THE AIR!
COMO ESTAS?
- UH, TIP-TOP.
YEAH, I FEEL, UH...
- OH, YOU SOUND OVER IT.
WHAT IS GOING ON
IN YOUR LIFE?
- UH, WELL...
TO BE HONEST...
I'M GONNA KILL MYSELF
TODAY.
[suspenseful music]
[sobbing]
♪
- I DON'T CARE!
DO YOU CARE?
- NO.
- DO YOU CARE?
- [shakes tambourine]
ALL RIGHT!
[maracas shaking]
[laughter and cheering]
- YEAH.
- [bleep] YOU.
[chicken caws]